da sind dann wieder zum dritten mal
wie ist die lage die lage die lage
kommen 25 erster und ist räume verfügen
läuft auch gut auf youtube ja super
alles okay vorverkauf läuft auf amazon
und als bombe dank für das gespräch
was hat sich für dich im netz jahr getan
im letzten jahr ausführlich getan ich
hatte eine sehr schwere zeit gehabt
warum letzten jahr oder als letztes jahr
oder das davor das ja zusammen also das
jahr davor 2011 war ein bisschen
anstrengend ging auf die knochen
das waren oft autobahn
viel unterwegs wir müssen auf die psyche
anstrengend war weil ich zum konzert hat
und parallel noch eine agenda zu machen
musste dorto gramm stunden und et cetera
und bla bla bla und dann kam 2012 des
anfang des jahres war die tour halt ich
halte mich viel so von der tour also
fuhren ja ja ich bin nicht wieder tun
und ja dann kam das album schon wieder
das was jetzt herauskommt war schon
düsseldorfer aufgenommen fünf monate
lang und wird alles gut weihnachten
geburtstag und silvester vielfaches cool
also ich festgestellt habe auch in
unseren interviews super lock
polarisiert wahnsinnig wohl eher sehen
heißt die einen finden sich sensationell
und die anderen finden dich grauen wie
kommt das ich weiß nicht wo muss also
keine ahnung ich bin letzten champagner
gewesen ja das ist komisch ja auf jeden
fall und keine ahnung ich bin
manche leute mich kuhlmann schon ist
jedem sein
was ist denn das was die leute so an dir
feiern beziehungsweise genau das
gegenteil machen was ist das womit
dieser auf keine ahnung ich bin einfach
ich bin den leuten das schlicht nicht
vorstellen
und manche fallen deshalb nicht weil es
zur rede gestellt
das ist und kein blatt vor den mund
nehmen
und mithelfen die finsternis bist du
denn so wie du aufstehst was gerade
gesagt was ein bisschen komisch vom
letzten mal wie bist du ich bin ja ich
bin so wie ich gerade über die sitze mit
der natur entspannt er entspannt mal
auch nicht so entspannt und aggressiv
und ein bisschen abgefuckt aber es sind
halt so ich bin ein typ der manchmal
stimmungsschwankungen hat aber habe ich
aber erst seitdem ich musik mache so war
das ist okay was macht mich aggressiv
macht keine ahnung wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel unterwegs bin und die leute
fakten ich habe also es gibt ja auch
coole fans von mir aber ich bin über in
deutschland unterwegs da kommt manchmal
sätze von überschreiten
nur weil ich nicht mit denn da sitze und
den er jetzt eine halbe stunde laufen
und gleich weiter muss euch zu tun habt
kommt komische sätze antwort wenn dann
feststellen wenn sich wenn die personen
das selber mal wenn ich versuchen zu
testen
meine persönlichkeit unbedingt ja wenn
du mich unbedingt für anwendungen zu
testen also ich kann ja wie gesagt
gerade wenn ich irgendwo unterwegs bin
und keine ahnung ich war gerade essen
dann laufe ich hatte ein paar besoffene
zum beispiel hannover am steintor her da
laufe ich da im steintor um und war grad
essen besorgen da kommen muss jetzt ein
getränkehalter schön trinken und dann
wenn es dann so weit geht dann sagen
alter fick deine mutter du [ __ ]
gemessen ok hat mich absolut scheiße
gaal oft meine musik hat oder nicht
wieso hat dass die devise war es vor der
musik war so ausgelegt
warum ist das in hernals ich dann zu
weil ich da in ruhe auf dem konto bus
konnte weil ich da machen konnte was
wollte und jetzt geht es leider nicht
mehr was ich gehe seit einem jahr nicht
mein clubs feiern so echt dass wir gar
nicht mein clubs ist mit mein
hotelzimmer und nacht privatparty so
okay aber ich gehe nicht mein clubs geht
nicht das heißt was passiert wenn ich so
oder so wenn ich daneben benehmen das
geht halt nicht das passt nicht und ich
bin halt so ein mensch der gern trinkt
mal aus der reihe tanzt okay und
deswegen ist ungerne frankfurt unterwegs
also raus in clubs weil es auch dann oft
stress gibt und flaschen fliegen und
stühle
und alles was dazugehört ist kein bock
raus ok liegt das an die an deiner
persönlichkeit oder liegt das daran was
die leute von mir denken ja wie gesagt
die leute versuchen immer mal testen so
was ist ihr habt das stabiles da rein
komme und keine ahnung computerwelt
weder fleisch noch maroder so dass
fucked up so lässt und es kann ich mir
sparen oder im krieg gewalt und scheiß
club 1000 euro oder 4 800 euro
ein schönes we can go und macht mich
locker so was so ziemann badermann plan
und so habe ich meine ruhe
vielleicht bin ich auch ein bisschen
erwachsener geworden was ist erwachsener
geworden
würde man einem neuen album nach bei
welchen zum beispiel manche spiegel
traurig aber wahr und auf der platine
seite wie zumba songs und auf der blog
seite habe ich auch stellt nun auch
generell ein bisschen ernster stimme wie
früher aber es auch ein bisschen ernster
geworden ist dass humor ich weiß jetzt
gar nicht aussprechen abos wissen wer
der böse mann versteht ja teilweise gar
nicht die zum teil verstehe ich gar
nicht erlaubt ist ich habe silber ich
brauche meine ich meine meine meine
tasche gerade ich kannst du gerne
übersetzt sich selber hin zu übersetzen
ja was auf eine sekunde
ich habe mir mal aufgeschrieben was ist
dass die leute denken meine texte sind
sinnlos
ich habe man notiert was verstehe ich
und passau 1 das ist ganz sicher etwas
verstehe ich und das war folgendes
ferrari sitz nase bricht bahnhof trifft
kopf ab ob audi spuren so ein luft
tricks kung fu tatort straße carlo habe
ich kaum noch richtig verstanden kommt
nicht vor ok straßen stark straßen
international verständlich gehört
strafen von international sind alle ok
ok ich hab es ist schon klar aber
teilweise unglaublich müssen wir der
bravo ist ist auf [ __ ] okay das
heißt junge war so sagt man uns kunden
auch bei den türken so ein typ seiner
respekt verwirrung muss wissen wer der
wahre ist haft jahre haft ihr großer
bruder okay aber ist er dem lambo
ferrari sitzt ferrari sitzt saudi
arabien which also ich bin gleich ins
audio chip reese saudi arabien which
wissen weder wo ist aktion französisches
walker erfahrung hat enzym machtlos hat
hitz machtlos keine bewegung alle kids
auf türkisch als game of tennis alter
bewegung attac bloß keiner hat jetzt
bevor ich komme und dir deine nase
bricht das richtig deutsch bevor ich
kommen und dir deine nase gab war ich
komme und diana sektor bevor ich komm
aus dir deinen brief wissen wer da war
wo ist immer noch derselbe djokovic
gleich junge enorm bahnhof trifft wie er
gerade nasen swift wir gerade namens
nicht wissen wer da war wo ist das level
ist kein rassist netten klageschrift ist
ein auto oder ein also rheiner bahnhof
alles hat man hat nur noch geld zu
machen haben die leute sind halt auch
unterwegs ist also auf jeden fall
textdruck hartkopf foto katja kopf hat
ist das ist kopf ab motor komplett
total.com bot vollkontakt aller umbach
was heißt alle augen buck sowie am bug
um wachsen film ok kennt in einer
warnbake am bug der typ mit den ellbogen
der kirche und dem schienbein und so ok
kenntnis von hollywood streifen hatte
oder er filmt kopf ab motor kommt von
tag darum bakom run homerun handel
kommen
er ist ein opfer des honda ist sagert
aber setzten besonders honda sowie veit
am pressetisch honda ist und sagte man
da abwehren konnte
du bist honda ist ein paar boxen im
spiel
sage hat wie ok nich nicht link von
hinten
schau dich frontal zac hat also schau
dich frontal behindert oder gehen von
einer summe im schnitt nur schwer was
los besuchen so kommen wieder wenn du
luftkriegs pussy-club plus nicht ob
idowu die das ist jetzt mehr so heiß ich
ja musik nichts mit hollywood frankfurt
bruder bruder du kannst winkt schon ist
ein kampfsport und kunst sowie bruce lee
kommst du tust du dir das meine
stadtplaner aus dem osten der türkei gp
kurs 62 von der stadt die
nummernschilder in deutschland sehen wir
den buchstaben und der türkei sind es
allerdings zahlen okay und bei uns unser
tun soll es 62 konsulaten schicchi col d
mark
was war das nach der 62
der berner freuen als abräumer war die
62 wurde
ok die marke nutzt durchlöcherten den
tatort ohne dass herr strunk wo ist mein
sohn okay die schlechten den tatort ohne
und du legst danach dort rum straßen
mode tagesordnung
armin nack das heißt ich fick die von
monaco
es geht um schwarze porsches mit dem
markt nun motors macht nun motor sind
sowie abb bei mercedes auch porsche mit
dem motors vollgas monte carlo trugen
aller formula uno sowie formelhaft ja
wie barbie war wie stets baby ok acht
jahre barbie straßen star international
übliche kurdistan das heißt kurdistan
drei jahren also was heißt baby so lange
lebe ja lange liebe kurdistan ich mach's
ob die ba zu zehn sätze gesagt der fall
wahrscheinlich an meinen mangel denn
wirklich kennt wissen ja dass ein paar
typischen weiter dritter dabei ist doch
schwer zu verstehen also viele sagen mir
ich verstehe kein tor
sollte dies tue oder soll die natur
ja ja nicht ob mein channel drauf wird
das wird das drunter geschrieben hier
verstehe ich die ganze zeit echt höher
entweder wünsche dass eine stärke
zwischen feier zum beispiel
französischen ab ich verstehe auch kein
wort aber ich feiere das musikalisch
deswegen die stadt drauf so machst du
das deshalb ist der der text nicht so
wichtig willst du laut text am inhalt
der texte
was heißt inhalt kennen sie das essen
spielen sind da kommt rein sehen oder
deshalb zu wahren was heißt keinen sinn
es ist ein action verkauft ok wird ja
aber daraus kann ich mein sinn der
glaube aber dass zum beispiel das
französische tor von duca und ganz
aufgeht dann
ich möchte auch gerne aber ich halte das
musikalisch wasser macht sowas und die
leute es gibt leute die mich verstehen
aber die fallen das musikalisch aber es
gibt leute die das nicht verstehen und
das musikalischen sparen und trotzdem
auf meine seite um pro jahr die klicks
geben warum schenkt ihr geld nehmen wenn
ihr nicht unsympathisch findet und meine
musik gefeiert
ich hätte mir doch jedes mal geld mm
klicks gibt so schwarz sehen was ihr
macht fühlst du dich missverstanden als
missverstand missverstanden ich finde
was für behinderte gibt es in diesem
land sowie die nichts besseres zu tun
haben mit den ganzen tag auf meinem
kalender und [ __ ] alter arm nix
besseres zu tun oder was wünscht du dir
dass sie nicht mehr kommen soll diese
andere mütter beleidigungs mit doch
scheißegal dann sollen diese spuren so
nennen und was weiß ich was die da
machen
ich find's einfach nur lächerlich wenn
es den nicht gefällt dann so in dem
carla etwas anderes sein alter wo es ja
keine ahnung mozart oder beethoven aber
ich weiß es gibt 1000 verschiedene musik
sorgen aber warum kommt ausgerechnet
fakt bei mir die ganze ton auf meiner
seite
im endeffekt wunsch meine 34 millionen
klicks sind zwei drei monaten also
anscheinend doch nicht so schlecht
es gibt leute die sphären wieder nicht
polarisieren da kommt zurück
ja jedem science frisst sich das
manchmal gar nicht krank ich lach mich
irgendwo her
so wirst du zum beispiel zwei stunden
kommentare lesen okay weil sie schlafen
konnte ja gibt's nicht mal so ein schlag
in die magengrube
oder denkst der hat sich getan hat also
wenn es anfängt zu manchmal lustige
sätze müssten so setzten den weg sind
schon mal lustig was sie gar nicht
schlecht sind diese teilweise auch
poetisch sich die kleinen aber nutzern
anfing mit
landloser kunde
oder abschieben und schließe man den
ersten satz zu wachsen
den ersten satz
zunächst kann man damit einschlafen oder
ist es ja schlafen
im babyalter dann auf die kita
wir sagen immer härter sind auch klicks
bist du denn zufrieden mit dem wiso
gelaufen ist den letzten jahren oder
letztes jahr anders gewünscht wird zudem
weniger väter wünschen zufrieden aber es
kann auf jeden fall besser besser laufen
ja immer
dann kommt geld geht wie gehts schnell
wodurch auch alles mit klamotten
leihwagen weil ich keinen bock auf
meinen wagen und leihwagen damit er
geklagt dann plötzlich kleiner bruder
denn dann zahlt man pro quartal nur
wenig des bereichen beteiligung bei
leihwagen pro quartal über 2000 euro
und dann teuren klamotten schmuck
ich denke es gibt leute die haben echt
siebenstellige summen verzockt in ein
paar jahren verzockt längst mensch ob
sie aus sich heraus ja aber ich bin ist
siebenstellig sechs stelle kam ich auf
jeden fall für hotel paradies nicht nur
vorurteile partys überhaupt halte
düsseldorf 100 riesen losgehen
programm mit 5 0 sieg nach hause
ok hast du nicht angst irgendwann mal
ohne etwas dazu stehen um mich weil ich
da musikalisch viel zu stark ich bin ja
auch nicht so mensch der die ganzen
klubs abhängigkeit erzählt habe sondern
spieler haben es auch sehr oft zu hause
und schreibt den ganzen tag ich habe
zuhause locker 200 text herumliegen oder
300 so und die ich einfach nur mit einem
system in dem ich aufbau mixtapes
raushauen kann ich locker zehn mix
selbst soll ebenso was also es wird
immer wieder was kommt jetzt
ich denke mal wenn ich dieses jahr 56
schließen sollte ist auch schon ganz
schön mein album kommt also ich habe auf
jeden fall für die nächsten fünf sechs
jahre macht minister viel gedanken aber
danach kommen muss man gucken erzählt er
dass ein krasser gangster ich bin und
was hat es eigentlich mit der realität
zu tun in deutschland gangster realität
mit der realität realität realität kommt
im alter wenn man die reha muss sagt
realität wahrheiten leute realität was
ist denn realität ich keine ahnung es
gibt einen hohen sind überhaupt dass das
sage okay
obwohl es da ganz normal realitäten im
sommer sagt stellen welche hohen so sagt
er denn nämlich die person auf jeden
fall ja realität auf jeden fall nicht
was realität ist doch mal die frage war
was was hat dieses image des gangsta
rappers in paar jahren kann ich das
nicht erzählen mit der realität zu tun
bist du gangster jetzt oder vorher oder
ganz ehrlich mir ist schon was zuletzt
es ja noch gangster auf einer art und
weise vielleicht jetzt nicht so dieses
jahr nicht alles nur ums leben aber die
platte gemacht wenn die blogseite
irgendwann mal der vergangenheit an
stoffe nicht also ich find's cool so
klar zu machen
ich bin kein zahle meine steuern ganz
normalen wie der deutsche bürger
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen mehr als
manch andere deutsche bürger aber ich
sag mal wenn ihr 5000 in fünf monaten
100 100 100 100 riesen durchgehend 110
102 anschließen dann muss man auch nicht
nur ein zuhause euro am tag macht es ist
auf jeden fall eine menge steuer
woher kommst du willst du nicht über
meine mutter kommt aus dem schwarzen
meer
naja ausgeht dass sich die stadt um mein
vater ist aus dem osten der türkei
ja also meine mutter ist praktisch
türken ja aber lasst türkin ja wie mit
den last türkin las nennt man sowas das
ist schwarze meer okay also diese oben
am schwarzen meer hat man leute ja und
im osten aus dessen stelle
da kommt mein vater so ich bin halb
türke wurde also wieso ist das ist zwar
muss man ja sagen in der türkei auch zum
teil verfeindeten ja aber es wird auch
immer lockerer
ja also ich hab zu hause die politisch
in alabama gehabt also mein vater war
voller offene menschen und wenn ich
meine mutter geheiratet
deswegen redet türkisch ja ich kann
leider kein kurdisch ok es wege jedes
stück ich es heißt ja nicht umsonst
muttersprache und sagte ich bin kunde ja
was die meisten leute nicht verstehen
fühlen sie sich manchmal ein bisschen
zerrissen oder und so schließt das hier
unterdrücken zu sein der mit türkischer
abstammung unter türken er mit coach
türkischer abstammung problematik
natürlich auch cafés wo ich nicht so
gerne
ja das sind dann so faschisten ja um den
halte ich nichts das heißt die sind
gegen kurden diesen gegen das heißt er
dürftest du nicht rein oder das geld
rein ja kein problem damit aber 5
oder dass kraft aber ich halte nicht
viel von radikalkuren sie sagen alter
türke steht das geht nicht
neben europa und solltest du hast
langsam alter diesen 2012 alle das alles
geldmacherei
dessen politik ist komplette
geldmacherei also ist doch scheiß egal
wo man herkommt
aber hauptsache mensch ist mensch also
aber eine gefragt haben bei uns sagt man
wissen also wo kommst du her aus der
türkei und die frage wo damals
wahrscheinlich öfter gestellt als geht
es ja ja das gerade so politische zeit
war mein vater hat immer gesagt ich bin
von dieser welt ehrlich gesagt ich bin
von dieser welt keine ausrede sein
es war seine antwort zu den leuten stolz
auf den er guckt aber für urteil kann
sich jemand sagen keine ahnung auch wie
wenn du wissen amerika und die ganze
zeit schwarze ruft einer grußadresse so
sachen allem aus einer du kommst nicht
verraten
mit den hier vorankommen kannst kannst
du was mir stößt sie machen können weil
seine welt so kleines verstehst du unter
finden sie spielt in der truppe und
sagen okay wir sind jetzt gegen türken
und wir sind jetzt gegen
wir sind 80 das ist neu für mich idioten
aber die waren auch nicht viel spaß an
ihrem leben haben
so legen diese einstellung auch in
frankfurt alle brandorte sohn und
multikulti gibt's nicht in deutschland
somit mehr sind und so kommst du mit
vorarbeiter weder ein [ __ ] hat bock
auf dich wieder neuen deutschland auf
dich wenn du dich da findest du
vielleicht fünf freunde alter dann würde
ich auf eine nationalität wurde und
schönberg nichts zu tun haben ob sie
nicht vorangeht hat das denn ein bekommt
das in deiner musik vor was dann kommt
es auf dem neuen album vor ja ich habe
einen song gemacht er ist sehr sehr geil
besonders trauriger war
ich zähle allendorf
ich bin das kind das in palästina
freiheit schreibt du die scheiße kugeln
die gerade fliegt auf mein leid ich bin
der vater der meka grab zu aller ruft
nun eine lüge wie ein hinweis für die
freiheitsstatue
ich bin der immigranten niederland der
asyl will der villa der mir sagt das
kokain hilft ich bin der mann den keiner
hand halten not du nur der scheiß
gedanke treibt zum alkohol
ich bin das kind in afrika das camp für
sein brot du der kapitalist der profit
schreckensjahren stück nach oben und ich
weiß nicht ob meine seele kriegst du ich
bin und bleibe suchen von gott das ist
schon ein gedicht alter
das ist dann wieder der erwachsene haft
ok und der haft wird jetzt erwachsener
auf jeden fall ballack ist was es hier
geht und als cool
super vielen dank